Russian President Vladimir Putin is in  Saudi Arabia where he's expected to sign  oil agreements and to discuss the crisis  with Iran this is his first visit in  more than a decade maybe assigned the  two countries aren't getting closer  he's meeting King Salman also the Crown  Prince Mohammed bin Salman in Riyadh  Saudi oil facilities you'll remember  came under drone attacks last month  which the u.s. blamed Russia's Ally Iran  for we'll have a closer look now at  Russia's relations at Saudi Arabia two  of the top oil producers in OPEC have  worked together to reduce supplies so  that prices stay relatively high but  they've been on opposing sides on a  number of issues notably Syria and Iran  the two nations have also discussed  cooperating on missile defense which is  controversial for the United States  because Saudi Arabia currently relies on  US made systems which Washington  recently agreed to strengthen